Beth talked about dancing on set before
that you all both dance and we I heard
about your dancing yeah yeah I heard
about your dancing wasn't it with Prince
the last time we were like yes that's
right oh I remember yeah oh I don't I
dance with Prince
so what so you're only cool a little bit
Yeah so I wanted to show you there but
still yeah I wanted to show this Tick
Tock that you made oh boy so here we go
so here's my
we've come so far from Prince like is
what I'm
so wait wait who who got you to do that
was it your idea my daughter it was your
daughter my daughter and her friends
were over they've been begging me to
join Tick Tock
making a tick tock is a whole process
but anyway so they set up the camera and
the three of them are standing behind it
going this is how you do the moves and
let me tell you there were multiple
takes and I was being again abused
um verbally this time I was like guys
this isn't easy for me
um but we finally I think we finally
came out to it it it it it it worked out
it worked out we got to a place where
everybody was happy okay I just feel
like who do you think the best dancer is
on set if we're gonna have to be honest
about this guy who did you say play feel
like it's me
no no
no I think it goes Cedric I actually
have never seen tashida dance she's
dance above her no I'm putting her at
the bottom I've never seen it I'm gonna
put Tashina at the bottom because I know
okay she's got the best voice by far by
far but so I'm gonna go Cedric and then
I'm gonna say me and then I'm gonna say
that
you saw that Tick Tock we did that's
what he thinks that dancing is and
Prince I saw the prince thing too so
wait I I have a band so I was just
thinking that maybe we could have a
dance off here I was just thinking
oh yeah wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait okay okay wait I'm doing it
okay
[Music]
thank you
we need to do another quick break more
without
them
[Music]
[Applause]